hey this is presh talwalker a teacher
has a rope with the length equal to l
centimeters
using the entire rope he forms the edges
of a non-square rectangle with area
equal to a centimeter squared what is
the length of the smaller side of this
rectangle in centimeters in terms of L
and A this is adapted from the 2016
Chile PSU exam
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so let's visualize this process we have
a rope with length equal to l
using the entire length of the Rope the
teacher forms a non-square rectangle
with area equal to a
suppose the shorter side of the
rectangle is equal to X and the longer
side of the rectangle is equal to y
we want to solve for x
so because the Rope has length equal to
l we know the perimeter of the rectangle
is equal to l this means 2y plus 2X is
equal to l
we will solve this equation for y
subtract 2x from both sides and then
divide by 2 to get Y is equal to 0.5 L
minus X
we now know the area of the rectangle is
equal to a so x times Y is equal to a
substituting in for y we can then
simplify this equation to get 0.5 XL
minus x squared minus a is equal to 0.
so let's focus on this equation
we'll multiply both sides of the
equation by negative 2 to give the
quadratic equation 2x squared minus XL
plus 2A is equal to 0.
we then use the quadratic formula to get
X is equal to l plus or minus the square
root of the quantity L squared minus 4
multiplied by 2 multiplied by 2A and
this is all over 2 multiplied by two
this simplifies to be L plus or minus
the square root of the quantity L
squared minus 16a all over 4.
we just have one final detail
we have two sides of the rectangle X and
Y and we want to solve for the smaller
side which we have labeled as X so we
have X Which is less than y so there are
two possible solutions to this quadratic
equation and the longer side the Plus
Solution will correspond to Y and the
shorter side will correspond to
subtracting the radical
therefore X is equal to l minus the
square root of the quantity L squared
minus 16a all over four and that's the
answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time